爷爷就挣4000块钱，
人家还要养老，
诶，
老了之后，
你以为他能靠得住这俩儿子吗？
每个儿子都找一个像你这样的媳妇儿，
她靠得住谁？
他俩儿子都靠不住，
他也得养老啊，
他也得为自己活着去储备粮食啊，
是不是你不要希希望与婆婆帮你带孩子，
她帮你带孩子了时候，
她那个养老的问题你就一定能扛吗？
对方呢，
是29岁，
家里的话只有妈妈、
弟弟，
还有一个年纪比较大的还没有结婚的一个姑姑，
他的父亲啊，
爷爷奶奶大概在四五年前的话呢，
因病相继就去世了，
家里的话在农村有两层楼，
是高中学历，
目前收入的话是一年13~14个，
相对比较稳定。
我的话呢，
是30岁，
家里兄弟姐妹四个，
我是老大，
我家里是做生意的，
在市区里面有房子有车，
本科学历，
目前的话是一个事业的状态，
个人的话呢是有双向，
一直有去那个小片，
然后，
但是目前是一个稳定期，
我俩的话呢，
谈了三四年，
我跟他在一起的话，
感觉是挺舒服的，
就是可以做自己，
他也很尊重我，
对我也算是挺大方的，
有时候我比较焦虑的时候也比较依赖他，
当然了，
有时候我也有在向下，
就是包容他，
我纠结的点是他妈妈催我们结婚，
但是在经济上面不怎么。
出钱就是一直说自己没钱，
然后呢，
我又感觉他有点妈宝，
有点愚孝，
就是喜欢对家里奉献自己，
因为之前他家里三个亲人生病，
都是他出钱买药什么的，
他也供自己的弟弟上大学，
有一次呢，
就跟他们家人在外面吃饭，
他就当着大家的面问他妈妈说他结婚了啊，
能帮多少，
他妈妈就说啊，
只能当个一两万吧，
他妈妈的工资呢，
在我们那个当地是有4000多，
是一个小酒店的一个经理，
我感觉呢，
他妈妈是比较偏爱他弟弟，
对他的话呢，
是一个索取金钱的，
这种感觉就是当他是家里的顶梁柱了，
他家里不是有两套安置房的名额，
6名两套的话需要20多30个拿色吧，
但是因为我不是很想要置房，
所以我最后跟他商量了，
他就不要他的那个名额，
4月份的时候在老家的市区买了房子，
写了我俩的名字，
我给了5个，
那会儿我跟他吵架，
因为他家里不出钱，
最后我去跟他妈妈要了5个，
这套房子我们就拿下了，
最后我跟他商量说他妈妈给那个5个，
我们拿去买五金好了，
他也同意了，
也跟他妈妈说了，
9月份的时候我们去买了五金，
也就把那5个花了，
后来他妈妈又催结婚啊，
当时他妈妈也不说了。
出钱什么的，
因为这个我跟他吵架，
8月回去跟他妈妈争取，
他妈妈就答应说酒席的钱他妈妈出，
他就说他妈妈出酒席前的话收到了礼记也给他妈妈，
他现在觉得不太舒服的是，
他妈妈就是比较强势，
比较自私吧，
我有点担心我结婚以后过不好，
也担心他妈妈不给我带孩子，
也担心他就是到时候有我跟他妈妈有什么矛盾，
他又不帮我，
我们也会经常因为他妈妈不给钱这个事情吵架，
但是他又去争取了两次，
也就是刚刚急躁的，
他也跟我说他妈妈不帮他，
他也没有办法，
我感觉有点无奈啊，
可能我心里面也有点不平凡，
因为我家里的话，
他是比较重视我，
首付的话也给了我5个了，
后续装修的话，
我家里人现在也已经给了我几个，
我就特别担心，
就是他妈妈这边以后对我不好，
他也不算在我这边也没有人发现我们带孩子什么的，
就有点焦虑，
我想问，
就是这样子的话，
你应不应该继续下去，
因为你自己是有双向的，
这是我们的一个致命的弱点。
如果说我们自己有双向的话，
对于我们来说，
择偶的标准可能更多的是要把我跟谁在一起的时候，
我心态是更平和的，
我更容易稳定病情，
更不容易激发出我的恶。
我的极端和我的这种病情，
而不是应该把物质条件放在第一位，
这是我个人的一个观点，
如果说你的家庭条件好，
你的家庭愿意为你付出的话，
这是你的福气，
而他的家庭条件不好，
他爸爸已经去世了，
没有人助力他的话，
这是他的劣势。
但是你不能要求说因为你的爸爸妈妈家庭好，
条件好，
所以你要求他的家庭要跟你的爸爸妈一样的付出，
那是做不到的。
你在选择这个人的时候，
一定有轻重缓急，
有取有舍的，
如果我娶的是他，
不在意我有双向，
我娶的是我跟他在一起是安心的，
不容易激发出我的恶，
也不容易激发出我的病情的，
那同时的话，
我要舍弃这些东西，
可能舍掉的这个东西就是他物质条件没有我那么好，
就是，
就是因为我跟他在一起，
我感觉他自己的情绪比较稳定的，
如果说情绪不稳定的唯一一个影响条件就是我觉得他家里对他不好，
对我不好，
这个就是唯一会影响我们感情的一个因素，
那这个因素其实有一个釜底抽薪的办法呀，
我为什么要寄希望于他的家庭对他付出呢？
我从一开始我就不希望没有预期，
不期待他的家庭要为他付出啊，
我之所以找他，
我很清楚我自己的劣势在哪里，
就是因为我自己有双向啊，
而你听到我双向可能就害怕了，
就跑了呀，
为啥找他呀，
就是因为他情绪稳定啊，
而你不能既要又要。
还要不能又要他照顾你的情绪，
跟你在一起的时候能稳定住，
你又要求他物质条件各方面都能跟得上你的父母对你的付出，
我是不是应该要调整一下我自心啊？
因为可能在我的一个认知，
或者在我周围人的一个大家的一个生活里面，
都是父母就是可以帮助自己的孩子啊，
父母就是会爱自己孩子，
所以我遇到他这种情况，
我是很不理解，
你都说了，
他妈一个月就挣4000块钱，
换做是你一个月就挣4000块钱，
你拖着俩儿子，
你能帮上什么忙？
很多东西就是位置一换，
你就看到不一样的画面了，
假设今天你带着两个孩子，
你一个月挣4000块钱，
你能帮上什么忙？
好的，
那我应该是把自己的一个心态去调整一下，
把人把的日子过好就是取舍，
姑要对于你来说什么最重要？
健康最重要，
心情舒畅最重要，
不犯病最重要，
同意吗？
同意好，
你跟谁在一起不犯病，
跟谁在一起稳定住情绪了，
你能够像正常人一样的过日子，
那他都是我的恩人了，
都是我的贵人了，
都是我该珍惜的人了，
我还在乎说他他妈妈能帮上忙吗？
他妈妈能给他钱吗？
我还在乎这个吗？
我也是跟他传过几次，
然后他也会去跟他妈妈争取他其实他说自己。
需要很大的勇气去回去，
你帮我争取到了，
对于他来说是不是也是一进步了，
这不叫进步，
这叫妥协，
某种程度上是他需要你的表现，
也是他爱你的表现，
这不叫进步，
这叫妥协。
我应该怎么跟他妈妈相处吗？
最好是少相处，
最好是不相处，
最好是不要期待他妈妈帮你带孩子，
如果他妈妈不帮我带孩子的话，
你一个人不太行，
那就先不要生，
什么时候等你们攒了钱了，
有了存款呢？
可以，
比如说你三年不工作也行，
有这个存款在了，
你再考虑生孩子，
他们个月就挣4000块钱，
人家还要养老。
诶，
老了之后，
你以为他能靠得住这俩儿子吗？
每个儿子都找一个像你这样的媳妇儿，
她靠得住谁？
她俩儿子都靠不住，
她也得养老啊，
她也得为自己活着去储备粮食啊，
是不是啊，
你不要希希望你婆婆帮你带孩子，
她帮你带孩子了之后，
她那个养老的问题你就一定能扛吗？
不一定，
你都不一定管人家养老的问题，
凭什么要求人家给你带孩子呢？
他说他不会要求我去管，
他一定会管，
我觉得是这样啊，
你如果上来不寄希望于他给你带孩子的话，
减少很多矛盾，
你寄希望于他给你带孩子的话，
难免会有矛盾。
其实我也考虑这个问题，
如果我强硬要求对方去帮我带孩子，
对方如果不愿意呢？
没有去带了，
可能会产生更多的矛盾，
他那个工作在我们那个城市来。
可以说相对来说比较好的，
如果他不工作的话呢，
他也没有收入，
可能别人也不愿意，
这个也是很正常的一个心理，
所以我就有点纠结，
应该不应该说是要强迫对方，
但是我自己又做不到，
因为我还有两个弟弟，
然后我妈妈这边可能帮不到太多我，
那你自己要考虑清楚哦，
凡事有取有舍。
还有一个问题，
现在我们是在一线城市，
那工作在一线城市相对来说是比较稳定的，
我们在老家买了房子，
我们想回老家生活，
但是他回老家的话，
可能找不到这么好的工作，
你应该就是要怎么办，
是在一线城市在工作几年存一点钱再回去，
还是说直接回老家，
但是现在工作的一个环境不好，
而且我也没有找到工作，
我觉得工作这个事情是尊重你的伴侣他自己的选择，
他如果觉得现在他年轻，
他在这里工作一年挣十几万，
他很自洽的话，
就不要说动不动让人家回老家，
然后你自己的话，
应该有自己的人生定位吧，
我怎么才能养活我自己呢？
我怎么才能有点存款呢？
我怎么才能将来不依赖于任何人，
等我想生孩子的时候，
我也养得起这个孩子呢？
这是我自己的人生定位，
不用着急结婚了，
不用着急往前推啊，
不用着急是吧，
先把自己的事情搞好了，
一定是这样，
姑娘，
一定是当你自己找到工作了，
你有社会关系，
你有这。
这个社会价值，
你有安全感，
你不害怕任何人离开你，
你不害怕任何人跟你分手，
你都能养活你自己，
你才会心态发生很多变化。
那个时候的话，
凡事都是自立自强，
我自己能怎么解决这个问题，
而不是上来就说他要为我付出什么好，
因为我前几天还跟他吵，
他还说过几天回去跟他妈妈说能不能争取一点，
在结婚上面再帮他一点。
天跟你这么聊了一下，
我想着跟他说不要回去跟他妈妈说这些东西了，
因为他这个妈妈说这些东西他们会吵架，
然后我跟他们说不要吵架好不好，
他说做不到不吵架，
一说起这些东西就会吵架，
我也不想说，
因为我的关系把他们的母子关系搞得更加恶化了，
那我就决定跟他说算了，
因为我想要的，
他能给我的，
他都给我，
因为我跟他妈妈的时候还是要相处的，
他妈妈有说候，
我不知道是说话怎么样，
故意还是无意的，
他说的一些话，
我感觉这能不好的，
然后我又会经常放在心上，
就会内好，
比如他妈妈第一次见到我就说什么我脸色不好，
生的孩子也不好什么的，
他就会这样说我，
我就说少接触吧，
我就说别指着他给你带孩子吧，
没错吧，
你指着他给你带孩子，
就给自己添堵啊，
是不是啊？
因为遇到这些我又不能怼回去，
我只能自一算问题，
你想问我什么问题，
我就是想问。
你对他做一些东西的时候，
我感觉到不舒服的时候，
我是应该回击他，
还是不理他，
忽视他，
看你对你男朋友感情的深度了，
如果你不想你男朋友为难的话，
反正就是他没听见来当放屁了，
如果你不怕你男朋友为难的话，
该怼就怼了，
该回嘴就回怼了，
我也跟他说过这些问题，
他就说你妈回去呀，
好了，
那咱俩就聊到这里啊，
好，
好谢谢，
嗯，
好，
拜拜。
我觉得如果我们自己，
比如说精神上这种心理上有一定的这样一个基础的问题在，
那对于我的择偶来说的话，
最主要的是看这个人跟我在一起的时候，
对我的身题好不好，
会不会让我情绪稳定，
会不会让我不犯病，
不狂躁，
不失控，
如果这个人跟我在一起的时候，
可以很大程度上去抚平我的这个心理问题，
那么其他的条件就要放开一点了，
未必要帅，
未必要有钱，
未必要怎么怎么样，
因为每个人最重要的东西就是你的身体健康，
你跟谁在一起，
他更能够维持你的身体健康，
那么其他的东西条件是可以放宽一点的。
这是我个人的一个理解，
就像我之前我直播间来了一个有点残疾的女孩子，
她脚有点走路的时候有点跛，
我就跟她聊过这个话题，
我说那我们可能就是最重要的是要看她心地是否善良，
至于她长得帅不帅，
高不高身材。
好不好，
这些东西都是其次的，
就是他本身，
你要看他是一个善良的人，
其次的话，
你有木强的心理，
我也能理解，
这里的强就要做广义的解释，
未必是他一定挣钱比你多，
他家庭条件一定比你好才叫强，
我是这么理解的，
就是你遇到问题，
遇到困难了，
你解决不了，
但是他在生活当中，
他能去解决这个问题，
也是他强的一方面，
他未必是去挣钱一定比你多。
记得点赞关注哦。